while many CS Pros like to get really
close to the monitor there was one
player who did things very differently
JDM who was a retired CS GoPro turned
valorant coach for FaZe has a signature
posture one that's so different in fact
that his former teammate Peta wasn't
sure that he was serious when I came in
first time I saw him I was like I don't
know if he's serious or he's tired his
signature play style is so iconic it's
become a legend in the Cs go community
in order to support the extreme angle
JDM props those feet up on something
under the desk now that's taken a
easy but if it works for him who
are we to judge
it's a one versus four awp push out good
shot JDM looks for another he's got this
down to one versus two over commitment
and perhaps a little bit zealous to try
an early end this oh no there is getting
down to the Box what is that from JDM
the ace clutch and we stay alive